let's jump over to this this story man
the near Times reports driver charged
with vehicular homicide in death of
Seattle protester the driver DeWitt
Collett a 27 struck two protesters with
his car early Saturday one of whom later
died prosecutor said now before we read
this they point out these women are
non-binary these they the women these
they are not binaries they these these
them's I don't know the right word is
what I call them well and binaries
binaries honestly non-binary this this
new thing about I mean I'm trying to be
ladies have you heard babies babies I
know Lydia's like oh I know there's a
new yeah babies they call them babies
because they're not giving them a gender
yeah they're children okay well I don't
work trying to talk about nurse
wait let me to be respectful and follow
the rules of YouTube okay if they're not
women okay they're so I don't know what
to say
Haman Haman terrible thank faman damn it
works
no it's got it's got the word men in it
and that's that's fine that's a
triggering we're gonna call them a
privilege or bone a privilege that
triggers me Haman Haman it has it there
they're not men so am i no no I think
that actually works I mean that in all
sincerity they Minh
yeah they yeah and men as in humans like
man woman and vaiman what else is there
award on non binaries Haman okay so so
they Minh are non-binding saimin are
non-binary so let's see if New York I'm
gets it right when they talk about it
let's read the news here a Seattle man
how do they know that oh did he tell
them
are they assuming is generally sure I
mean that literally though look at the
beginning of the next paragraph to the
man that's so weird to do it up as
weirded they do that though I mean at
least they're not throwing a race word
in there - why don't they just say do it
collect a you know let's read it a
Seattle man who authorities said drove
into a protest on a closed section of
Interstate five of the weekend killing
one demonstrator was charged on
Wednesday with vehicular homicide
vehicular assault and reckless driving
the man
DeWitt Collett a27 is being held with
bail set at 1.2 million dollars
why it was an accident yeah clearly
welcome to the morality police in world
man get out of the cities get away from
these people I'll tell you what they
will break into your house you will
defend yourself and you will go to
prison so it seems they will dance on
the highway
think about how insane that is I don't
care if it's closed or not this dude
clearly wasn't intending to hit them now
he gets a 1.2 million dollar bail he
gets a go to prison two of the charges
vehicular homicide and vehicular assault
are felonies a spokesman for the
Prosecuting Attorney's Office said they
have destroyed this man's life now I get
it
he was driving he had two people one of
them died
they say straight-up it's not murder
it's a manslaughter charge meaning it
was it was an accident he wasn't
supposed to be on the highway they don't
clarify how he got on the highway but it
was not an intentional killing his life
is now over because he is stupid and
that's about it and they wanted to dance
on the highway the Washington State
Patrol and FBI were still investigating
the matter and mr. keleti could face
additional charges according to a
statement from the prosecutor's office
the authorities said that mr. keleti was
driving a white jag jaguar xj l when he
drove into the protestors at a high rate
of speed early on Saturday morning
striking two protesters you see they
just keep saying protesters instead of
yeah more sheep one of them some are
Taylor of Seattle died later that day at
the hospital another protester Diaz love
of Portland Oregon was hospitalized in
serious condition a sobriety test
indicated that mr. Kleck day was not
under the influence at the time
according to a police report Diaz loved
who like summer Taylor uses non-binary
pronouns shared a hospital selfie on
Facebook this week with a message saying
that they were alive and stable no they
wait wait wait no they weren't one of
them died they meaning the one person
are you talking about - the the
paragraph talks about two people and all
yes they would have to say they is that
is or direct they is a live in stable
I'm not exaggerating
no no grammar grammar is being thrown
into a blender and shredded yes because
of this if you're going to be talking
about two people then they must follow a
singular so it should say they is alive
and stable that's a good point that's
that's true because it says Diaz love
like summer Taylor shared a hospital
selfie
I cannot believe summer was murdered
murdered they wrote
if they thought this this murder would
make us back down
they are very wrong who's they now who's
they I can't is ridiculous my gosh
language is supposed to help us
understand what's happening and the I
kid you not when I read this I was like
wait they're alive no but she was
murdered what is she talking about
oh they what is they talking what is
they talking about and it wasn't murder
it wasn't first well with a murder there
I'm sorry
they look man I'll tell you what they
I'm not I'm not saying this in any way
to be disrespectful or funny what I
can't understand when I want it when I'm
reading and they say oh you know what
you're talking about
if the New York Times writes a paragraph
with multiple people in it and then says
they are alive why would I assume a
singular at all so they need to use they
can't use the pronoun here it would have
to say to be completely fair that uh
Diaz love shared a hospital selfie with
a message saying that Diaz was alive it
would have to use her name yeah you
correct Yanis you in it and then that's
messed up
summer wait Diaz calls it murder as well
and you can tell that's that's the
emotional side that that will never
relinquish because my friend was
murdered
my fellow protester was murdered by this
person and it's like Haman I read the I
write it into the the police report and
like he constantly was asking if they
were okay he was he felt terrible it's
like there's no way that they got
murdered that is a ridiculous claim like
he felt he felt terrible he has a strong
family like they're all that immigrated
here legally do working it's like it's
said I'm so ready to just shut
everything down and just take the van
down to the river man I'll take over
think about how stupid this is at the
New York Times wrote a nonsensical
paragraph to placate this this person
for this story well they they prefer
they pronouns so now we're going to
break the paragraph and I'm supposed to
understand and just know I tell you this
if they're right if a regular person was
reading this they would assume they were
both alive yeah that's true it mentions
two people and says they
alive and then the very next sentence is
they were can't believe they were
murdered
summer was murky like wait what well
technically it's they because they're
both days right so no so yeah they were
murdered yeah here they say the episode
was followed dozens of similar incidents
involving cars striking demonstrators
yeah yeah yeah we know all about it huh
it was not clear which incidents were
premeditated in which were prompted by
rage as drivers found their routes
blocked by protesters I'll go ahead and
save very few of them there's a story
out of New York City near it was on 42nd
it was nearly I think near Bryant Park
and an SUV was trying to drive down the
street yes all the protesters went up
gonna block it the car stops they start
yelling you got to go another way and
the guy's just sitting the event that's
if he's not moving well he couldn't they
were surrounding they were jumping on
his hood right and then somebody says
pop is effing tires well actually they
saw where they even say that you can
hear someone took the thing off yeah
they're hit they were draining a tire
the hissing of the air popping out or
kind I mean people start hitting the car
and so he speeds up and they start
screaming get out of the way get out of
the way and then he takes off he drags a
bike and then the story was SUV plows
through protesters it's crazy dude I'm
not I'm not in a good mood about any of
this stuff the media has no credibility
no they could have none of these people
actually watched any of the videos
correct they didn't bother to they
didn't do their job these people don't
do their job anymore could you imagine
if I had a plumber and he typed your
house and just went in the living room
and like played video games you'd be
like bro I'm not hiring to do this and
be like well I'm on the clock to bed
yeah but with journalists people just
assume they must be correct yeah the
journalists have realized this well
they're not journalists they're not
journalists anymore they're there I'm
talking about
ny1 I know they're actors yeah that's
what it is they're just TV TV actor
exactly and then they just get a robot
to write up a generic fake article you
know no one has any idea what happens
and then everyone else rewrites the same
trash mr. Kalidas lawyer John Henry
Brown told the AP that he was remorseful
over the incident and there's absolutely
nothing political about this case
whatsoever mr. keleti lives with his
parents in Seattle so what are they got
to put up they gotta put a 10% for him
to get out of jail under this guy's you
know he works for door - yeah and now
he's gonna go to prison because he was
just dumb look I I think these laws are
so stupid
so stupid I'm totally down with prison
reform how does it make sense that
someone who did not intend to kill
someone is facing a 1.2 million dollar
bond
I don't know right the criminal intent
Wow it's it's isn't you know man now
they're using this they're using this as
fuel to burn to get more angry emotional
outbreaks from the people that they
think are winning this this civil war
this mental civil war that we keep
talking about that's what it is it was
in a place in your bets this guy should
have been let go right away the guy in
New York read the guy in New York got
taken into custody and release
no charges yeah exactly no I mean he
didn't kill anybody grand right you know
so this this actually did result in a
death which is which is terrible but he
he did not he didn't murder anybody it
was absolutely an accident they don't
know how he got on the highway for all
we know that it could have forgot one of
the exit or the entrances he could have
just been going up like GP the GPS might
have just been like take her right on
towards and boom followed it up did they
put a hard road block in the highway
right what if he's not what if he got on
a long time ago right yeah and what if
you were reading
wrong they don't even know yet so how
are they adding this and making this
what they're slamming on him when they
don't even have all the information well
maybe maybe they'll go to trial maybe
maybe he'll win but you think this guy's
gonna be able to afford a real attorney
a real lawyer to defend him no I
certainly want to give him a little bit
of help yeah seriously so here's I
pulled up the the state law for
Washington they say vehicular homicide
it is a manslaughter charge a crime
related to manslaughter as Vick Euler
homicide which is defined as a death
caused by any type of motor vehicle
including a car SUV taxi motorcycle
truck or bus under state law any death
that occurs within three years after an
auto accident due to injuries incurred
in the accident can be considered Vic
Euler homicide if the accident was
caused by another drivers negligence why
sends someone to to Y charge him with a
felony and put him in prison for several
years over what's obviously an accident
to make an example out of him yeah but
what's that gonna do nobody knows it's
gonna cause more disruptions more people
being upset no I'm talking about the law
general outside of all of this okay like
these laws are everywhere how
it never made sense to me when there
like somebody is driving a car and it's
negligent not malicious and the into an
accident and they're sad and they're
upset and it was an accident and they
have no intent on committing crimes ever
again and so you're like yeah but we
think we should just totally destroy
your life and lock you for several years
yeah not only do you have the death of
someone on your on your conscience
forever without the intent to actually
kill them exactly an accident they say
accident yeah yeah I mean I that's
that's what I was saying the other day
like I feel bad for this guy because I
mean he was in the car he heard them hit
the car and he tried stop and
continually continually asked the cops
are they okay I tried stopping I want to
know if they're okay please tell me if
they're okay and he clearly and they
they came after him so he drove further
away it's like he didn't drive away he
waited for them man I feel bad for him
he's got it on his conscience it's like
that is enough that's that's terrible he
didn't he didn't do it on purpose class
a felony it's insane if a person commits
vehicular homicide under the influence
of drugs or alcohol an additional two
years will be added to the sentence so I
believe as a felony it's probably a
minimum of one year
I don't know entirely you know it could
be different than what in in in
Washington but what about the people who
are on the highway don't they have
responsibility for breaking the law or
who let him there who is letting them
stay it's not even about who let them
nobody did it but but they broke the law
by being on the highway of obstructing a
highway that's a good point they have no
responsibility or any of these other
people can be arrested no I'll tell you
what arrest this guy lock him up for me
for vehicular homicide
I get the laws in the books and every
single person doing that stupid shuffle
dance should get charged for whatever
the charge is for obstructing a highway
the police won't do it and and for
causing a what yeah what causing an
accident for causing a death not every
single one does the people in the
highway should be to be charged with
some comment agree with you yeah
absolutely but this is this is this is
the name of the game man this is why um
I want to get as far away from these
cities as possible it is in our faces
yeah they they you you will you will be
driving down the road they will jump on
your car they will shoot you and then
you will get arrested if you try and if
you try and do anything you know they
have given these people
blanche to just go around and do
whatever they want with with impunity
it's it's crazy yeah so can the feds
come in and do something about this
not this guy specifically but they were
on an interstate that's federal
jurisdiction right how about your charge
um trauma charge these people for
blocking the highways they keep doing it
across the country now there's no law
and order it's not gonna come from the
republic it's not gonna come from Trump
I have no faith in anybody uuugh you
know I look at what's going on in New
Jersey second with Jeff Andrew you know
you know what's going on with this Jeff
Andrews the guy who switched from
Democrat to Republican okay right so now
what do we what do we get we have a
district that is traditionally
Republican voting in a moderate right
leaning Democrat okay probably the
furthest left Republican in the
Republican Party yeah now that's fine
because Jeff Andrew I think is an okay
dude I don't agree with some of them
he's actually further right than I am
but if the whole party is being if the
whole if all of our political space is
being pulled to the left that even in
this this district it's Republican
they're gonna vote in you know a
left-leaning
technically a far left Republican by
Republican standards I'm not convinced
that whatever happens in November is
gonna rectify any of this these cultural
issues have nothing to do with politics
and politics come so far after the
cultural issues it's pointless
there's nothing I don't I'm sorry man
I'm being pessimistic but I don't know
what can be done at this point
yeah and Nathan s actually on that note
it's like they're they're mixing them
both together so you can't even you
can't even start an argument because
they politics culture it doesn't matter
to them it's all and this big mess of
that's what they're angry about it's
like well what are you anger about well
the culture and and and everything and
the the society and old political realm
it's everything's fault so you can't
even like start a conversation because
it's all of it together they combined it
we we have jumped so hard into
authoritarianism over the past several
months yep several years and this is
cultural there is no changing it there
is no resistance to the authoritarian
takeover there is no Republican there is
no conservative there is no right
leaning individual that is that is part
of a large resistance group that
challenges this stuff the closest thing
you have
- it is the intellectual dark web a
group of academics and and high-profile
individuals and some conservatives who
are challenging this what I mean to say
is of course there are people who are
Trump supporters conservative moderate
who all agree this stuff has gone too
far but there is no collective
organization that works like the Left
does to destroy our civil rights and
civil liberties true in California they
have literally voted the state assembly
in the state Senate to repeal civil
rights law from their constitution it is
happening in our faces
crazy across this country morality put
placing is taking over and there is no
organizing from anyone anywhere to
challenge it there's a little bit but
what what ends up happening you know and
what I've been seeing from a lot of
commentators is that conservatives sit
back and say wow this stuff is bad I'm
gonna vote for somebody come November
but the politics comes later
who said who's won who said that
politics is bounced right back right
Bart politics is downstream from culture
that's why everything always moved to
the far left because all of these big
brands think left is safe no one knows
what a line is for the left and no one
is challenging it and when you do you
get banned they think about you that are
standing up right now but but think
about the organizational power of the
left they have new they have dozens to
to hundreds of nonprofits that
manipulate light argot destroy harass
and the right has people individuals
sure and that's the weakness and that's
actually the core philosophy of each
side at in an in a sense yeah the the
right is individualist on the left is
collectivist so the left forms a
collective it's a bunch of dumb people
to send stupid emails they go out they
block highways committing a crime
nothing happens they tear down statues
how many people have been arrested for
tearing down statues and that's Trump
yeah and I think for the most part now
there's a handful of people the state
level who have been arrested okay but
you look at the sheer number of people
who have gone around doing this then you
look at the people who painted over two
letters of black lives matter in that in
that California town crime getting
charged of the hate crime this is it man
we saw it with kovat we see it now with
the riots if you go out and say
lockdowns are bad you're out you're
here's a here's a five
if I go to church remember when those
people went to church in their cars and
the cop went card a car giving out
tickets you know oh yeah but you can
dance on the highway no problem well now
it's even getting worse like people are
going to church and the black lives are
at matter movement is showing up and
screaming at the people going to church
yeah going into the church and like
shutting it down black lives matter and
it's like you guys are in the church
like what what are you fighting against
right now I thought it was police reform
and then now it's at you know bring down
the patriarchy and the nuclear family
and it's like what what is your what is
the goal you don't you know I don't
think I don't think anything's gonna
stop this no when Trump supporters the
bikers for Trump came out to that small
Ohio town mm-hmm and counter protested
the media said far-right violent all
that really negative stuff well I mean
every everybody but the far left is far
right to them so of course because of
the cultural institutions being
controlled by the ideological left so if
I think there's only so I think there's
a there's a couple mmm nah voting won't
change anything it's it's too late
electing a politician won't do anything
because then four then two years later
you will have an ideological backlash
from there from the fact that they're
banning conservatives they're banning
moderates you're not allowed to say
certain words or names so what do you
think happens in the next election if
Republicans win the Republicans will do
nothing they will not pass 230 reform
they they'll say well you know private
corporations it's a good argument
they'll argue about it and then two
years later the screeching ring left
will vote in there people take the house
and pass hate speech laws
they'll get their Supreme Court you know
nominees if Trump doesn't win then
they'll start they'll start making
rulings on what the First Amendment
doesn't actually talk about for you know
about hate speech so we can make hate
speech illegal I don't see I don't see a
way out
unless literally nine out of ten
Americans turn their front porch and
like put a flag up or something
asserting that we will not be bullied
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe
hit the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you